I've noticed like the more that I've
been around couples people tend to date
people that we kind of resemble them or
someone that they love like their mom or
something I don't know why that is again
it's probably the familiarity thing that
she just pointed out but I've I've I've
continued to notice more and more but
since being in La that a lot of people
tend to date people that kind of look a
little bit like them so it doesn't mean
that necessarily like it's the beauty
standard it's just beauty is not
subjective it's objective there's been
many studies like people tend to find
the same things attractive like people
might have like certain types where it
differs a little bit but in general like
it's not subjective